les violentes inondations qui ont touché
la vallée de la somme me pose
légitimement la question de la
prévention at on pris en compte les
risques inhérents à cette région en
écoutant la colère des habitants et des
élus locaux il semble en effet que rien
n'ait été prévu pour faire face à cette
catastrophe
un état des lieux qui va coûter cher à
l'état aux élus et aux sinistrés
stéphane breitner vraiment chape l'art
ce coup du ciel personne ne l'avait
prévu et surtout pas les services de
l'état le préfet s'en souvient encore
lorsqu'il est arrivé en poste il ya un
an et demi son prédécesseur lui avais
bien dit ici s'il ya un risque qu'on ne
court pas c'est celui de graves
inondations dénigrement localiser oui de
petites innovations oui une catastrophe
de cette ampleur
personne ne l'avait prévu j'aiderai
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens disent eh
oui moi je l'avais dit je l'avais mais
ils n'ont pas dû parler bien fort les
picards n'ont donc aucun moyen de lutte
contre les inondations zone la plus
touchée
abbeville ou deux quartiers sont sous
les eaux depuis maintenant trois
semaines
à la mairie on accuse l'état d'avoir
négligé l'entretien des 240 kilomètres
du fleuve
aucun entretien des rives de l'aude est
riche de la somme depuis nombre d'années
sauf au coup par coup quelques colmatage
ici et là des possibilités d'évacuation
sur la mer qui n'ont jamais été mises en
place la seule qui était mis en place
n'était même pas raccordés
électriquement pas de palplanches demi
pas de plan de renforcement
tout ça fait qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans cette situation
à qui la faute une rumeur a d'abord
accusé paris de se protéger en déversant
son trop plein d'eau dans la somme
maintenant on s'en prend aux
administrations première visée la
direction départementale de l'équipement
qui aurait négligé le curage du fleuve
mais ici on plaide non coupable le plus
rage n'est pas nécessaire en ce sens que
la somme ne transporte très peu
l'allusion il ya très peu de matière en
dépôt le creuset ça reviendrait à rendre
encore plus facile la communication
entre la nappe phréatique et le canal
lui-même et donc de ce fait rendre les
quantités d'eau à évacuer encore plus
importantes si tout va bien il faudra un
mois avant que la somme ne retourne dans
son lit
un plan de prévention des risques
d'inondation a été lancée en urgence
mais il faudra deux ans pour le mettre
en place
symbole de l'imprévoyance général cet
atlas des zones inondables
basé sur les inondations de 88 et 94 il
vient à peine d'être terminée
aujourd'hui il est bon pour les
oubliettes